rosa está avanzando en el este de
ucrania en el donbass las tropas rusas
han entrado ya en la ciudad de lis y
chance y ahora mismo allí las batallas
están siendo calle a calle y cuerpo a
cuerpo según su propio gobernador
regional y si chance el último bastión
del ejército ucraniano la región de
lugansk después de que severodonezk haya
sido tomada por las tropas rusas y
después de esa retirada del ejército
ucraniano tras cuatro meses de duros
enfrentamientos si finalmente las tropas
rusas toman en liza chance vladimir
putin estaría más cerca de lograr ese
objetivo que se había marcado para esta
segunda etapa de la invasión rusa en
ucrania que es controlar todo el donbass
la guerra continúa también en donges y
se teme que el siguiente objetivo sea la
ciudad de es la habían se en donges e
hay en estos momentos mucha población
que está siendo evacuada de todas esas
zonas y viajan hasta ni pro pero también
hasta harkis donde nos encontramos aquí
la guerra se ha intensificado también el
número de ataques con misiles de medio y
largo alcance y también con artillería
ha aumentado en los últimos días y
aunque las fuentes oficiales nos dicen
que hay peligro de que las tropas rusas
intenten avanzar y volver y volver a
ocupar territorios de esta región cuando
viajamos a esos pueblos las autoridades
locales verdaderamente tienen miedo de
que eso pueda ocurrir porque los ataques
han empeorado y han aumentado mucho en
las últimas horas